artiste française ou multiples facettes
ORL devient célèbre dans les années 90
par ses performances chirurgicales elle
veut montrer qu'il est possible de
disposer de son corps en toute liberté
et d'aller à l'encontre des dictas
esthétiques de la société j'ai fait tout
ça en fait pour mettre de la figure sur
mon visage donc de la représentation
c'est-à-dire que moi personnellement je
n'avais pas envie de faire spécialement
des opérations chirurgicales performance
j'aimais beaucoup euh mon corps et mon
visage c'était l'idée de remettre en jeu
cette image et euh pour faire une
nouvelle image pour m'inventer moi-même
pour me sculpter moi-même et bien sûr
faire quelque chose contre la nature une
nature qu'elle prend très vite à
contre-pied grâce à la chirurgie
plastique qu'elle va utiliser pour
transformer son visage au cours des neuf
interventions chirurgicales entre 1990
et 1993
elle réalise selon sa propre expression
son
autoportrait j'ai fait mettre ces deux
implants qui sont d'habitude des
implants utilisés pour les pommettes et
que j'ai fait déplacer en demandant à ma
chirurgienne de de faire un c'était à
New York un geste opératoire qu'elle
n'avait pas fait qui n'était pas censé
apporter de la beauté donc effectivement
si on me décrit et qu'on ne me voit pas
on peut penser que je suis un monstre si
on dit c'est une femme qui a deux bosses
sur les temples et si on me voit on peut
avoir un avis un peu différent son corps
devient ainsi une œuvre d'art et son
travail mondialement médiatisé notamment
à cause du bloc opératoire qui se
transforme en atelier d'artiste les
chirurgiens et infirmières sont habillé
en pacoraban et Orlan elle-même
orchestre l'intervention en lisant des
textes en dialoguant avec le public ou
bien encore en réalisant des dessins
utilisant son propre sonang je pense en
tout cas que c'est pionnier euh est très
très différent et que ça secouit
beaucoup de choses puisque on se
retrouve en 2014 et que je n'ai pas fait
d'opération chirurgicale depuis 93 et
que j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup d'œuvres
et dans des grands musées et qu'on me
parle toujours de ces opérations
chirurgicales donc je pense que j'ai
touché un air que j'ai fait quelque
chose qui a été extrêmement médiatisé et
médiatisé ORL est encore aujourd'hui
grâce à ses nombreux travaux de
sculptures et de photos exposé à travers
le monde entier